it is time for drew's news your cozy
little good news cat taking a warm nap
in your lap um
so uh rossie yes rossi ross matthew
buddy i love you there is big news out
there today are we gonna hit it oh let's
let's hit it a hard did you guys hear
this one
ben and jen getting they're getting
married what they're engaged again
people reports jennifer lopez is
sporting a green engagement ring from
ben affleck her sister linda shared a
pic on instagram with a huge
congratulations that went super viral
asap
and jennifer says green is a lucky color
for her um i mean it certainly is she's
wore that versace dress we all remember
that oh i remember that she has a big
piece of barbara krueger art that has
like green hummingbirds she's actually
like the green is a good color for an
important meaningful significant one
yeah well this is significant and i'm
obsessed with this i've always been
fascinated by people who like break up
and then years later get back together
am i the only one that's fascinated by
that you guys know because raise your
hand if you're into
second chances yes heat up those
leftovers honey get on they're still
good
i never looked at it that way that's all
i think about and i think too like was
she pining this whole time thinking
about him like did she watch gone girl
and be like oh why are you gone girl
[Laughter]
have you ever thought about getting back
together with an ex oh god yes i've
tried so many times and
um
well
you know it's funny because i always
beat myself up and i was like i am the
problem i am the common denominator of
like all the breakups
and then a few i've revisited and i'm
like
okay the problems i had i have overcome
and fixed and you're still in the same
place that's very interesting so it was
kind of a nice helpful thing for me
where i was like i don't need all the
blame for this not working yeah it is it
is fascinating because i think
relationships are as much about timing
as they about about the individual right
don't you guys agree so maybe this is
their time
i hope so i think we revisit because we
loved them
and they made us laugh or there was
something about them and those things
you know i've always had that sort of
profound question like when you break up
where does the love go
and i think this is
very hopeful for all the people who
are romantics out there yes and we do
love love around we do
[Music]